for the first time since the start of
the pandemic many churches held easter
service in person bianca holman takes us
to guardian angel cathedral where they
celebrated sunday mass
[Music]
the pews are filled at guardian angel
cathedral this is the first easter
sunday mass in a couple of years that's
not held on zoom or live stream being
together again means a lot for
worshipers especially on this
resurrection sunday even tourists made
time to attend in person it's it's you
know it's like your friends you know you
can talk to them online but when you see
them it's a much you know better feeling
i think particularly this year more
people feel comfortable coming back into
more crowded spaces and thanks be to god
at least in southern nevada right now
safety is still important to faith
leaders sanitation measures are
implemented and those who want to wear a
mask are encouraged father bob stokic
says it brings some joy to see people
smile and hear their voices say
hallelujah this service allows followers
to unite as one body of christ we also
leave
church as part of that body to continue
the redeeming work of god's love in our
world and i think we need reminders
to be able to have the strength to do
that it's god's house and here you can
you know feel his love father stokic
says he wants people to leave with
restored hope and to understand christ's
passion and death led to his
resurrection there's so much
bad news
we need to testify to the good news
that's around us the church also holds
morning mass services during the week
bianca holman live local now